we now have a new poll about americans
view
on the proposed but still not
passed coveted relief bill of joe biden
and democrats we'll be speaking to
democratic congressman ro khanna a
little bit later today and i'm going to
ask him what's going on and how quickly
does he think this is going to move
forward
but there is a new politico morning
consult poll
which shows that 76
of all americans strongly support or
somewhat support
the covet 19 relief bill this is the 1.9
trillion dollar bill not that tiny
600 billion dollar package that some
republicans propose this is the big boy
only 17 of americans somewhat oppose or
strongly oppose the package the rest
don't even have
have no opinion at this point and
stunningly
among republicans 60 percent of
republican voters
strongly or somewhat support the 1.9
trillion dollar
coveted relief package this is a
really big deal because in the united
in the st states over the last eight to
ten years
the level of political division and
polarization makes it really difficult
to ever have
more than 58 or 60 percent support for
almost anything
after the sandy hook shooting during
barack obama's presidency
there was something like 88 or 90
support for universal background checks
for firearm transactions of all kinds
this means eliminating
every uh mechanism by which you could
obtain a firearm without a background
check uh 88 90
support and it still didn't pass and if
you hadn't been paying attention to this
reality up until then
it was another reminder that our elected
officials
are not actually representing the views
of their constituents because if they
were with 88 to 90
support for that it would have passed we
now are seeing
essentially every republican although i
believe
if it comes down to it some republicans
will vote for the covid 19 relief bill
proposed at 1.9 trillion dollars
because some pragmatic republicans
recognize that their constituents want
it
but at this point you have 76 of the
country saying we want this
pass this it's been proposed
it's been voted on in the house joe
biden wants it democrats want it
uh presumably it would pass the senate
with 50 at minimum 50 votes and kamala
harris is the tie-breaking vote
and yet we aren't seeing any republicans
come out and say this is popular with
the american people and it's my
responsibility to represent them
76 support and even 60 percent of
republicans supporting this
and not a single republican for now
has said let's do this i want to vote
for this
so as i've said before let them vote it
down democrats should be spinning this
accurately as this has bipartisan
support
we're not talking about uh republican
senators who are against it we're
talking about with the people
76 percent of the country 60 of
republicans support this
there is rarely anything as bipartisan
when it comes to public support
as this where are republican elected
officials on it
pass it via budget reconciliation or
attempt to
let every single republican who is
committed to voting against it do it
pass it via budget reconciliation you
know you have the votes with 50.
uh joe manchin said he supports it as
far as i last saw that was about a week
ago
kamala harris would be the tie-breaking
vote have joe biden sign it
and if every republican really feels
confident that they can vote against
this without
suffering with their own constituents
let them do it
i don't understand who it is that
republican elected officials are
representing by opposing this certainly
not their constituents
are they i mean you know where we
typically go is are they representing
corporate interests
are they representing donor interests
are they representing
lobbyist interests i i don't exactly
know
uh but we know that um certain staking
out
certain positions for republicans
is very lucrative in terms of
fundraising and maybe that's all that
this is i don't know the answer we'll
talk to ro khanna about it a little bit
later today
but it's time to do it it's it's just
time to get it passed
if you can think of any reason why
democrats at this point
should not go forward with the 1.9
trillion dollar coveted relief bill
through budget reconciliation requiring
only a simple majority
let me know you can find me on twitter
at dpakman
one of our sponsors is susman and han
sussman and han has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and
other supplies to stay safe during
covid19
and sussman and han is the company that
i've
personally been going to for face masks
and other ppe
because i trust the products that they
sell and that's actually why we reached
out to them about becoming a sponsor
because
their prices are reasonable ordering is
simple
everything ships within 24 hours and
they just have
high quality products for this global
hundred year pandemic they've got
surgical masks kn 95 masks
n95 masks other useful things like
infrared thermometers face shields
sanitizers
sussman and han is also an awesome
company because they've donated over 65
000 masks so far
to healthcare institutions shipping is
free
on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can go to their website by
going to davidpakman.com slash mask
the link is right underneath this video
and they'll give you twenty percent off
when you use the coupon code david